[Musique]
le grand matin Sud Radio 7 heures 9
heures Patrick Roger
la transition numérique des
télécommunications bonjour Joël
l'essence va-t-elle de nouveau couler
dans toutes les stations où est-on dans
une impasse on va revenir avec vous sur
cette situation après l'optimisme
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir mais la
reconduction ensuite de la grève sur le
terrain on va aussi se pencher sur une
autre menace le numérique c'est votre
dossier beaucoup de cyberattax ces
dernières semaines quels moyens de
défense et puis nous évoquons aussi
l'affaire Mbappé et PSG qui passe par
les réseaux sociaux et puisqu'il s'est
passé aussi hier soir à l'Assemblée
nationale commençons donc Jean-Noël
barreau par les coupures de robinet pour
l'essence vous le gouvernement vous avez
engagé des réquisitions chez exson pour
que les salariés reprennent leur poste
ce qui a été fait un peu hier la CGT
engagé des recours quelle est la
situation ce matin ben écoutez oui vous
l'avez dit dès le week-end dernier le
gouvernement a pris un certain nombre de
mesures pour améliorer la fluidité de la
distribution des carburants libération
des importations libération des stocks
stratégiques et hier a été décidé
de première réquisition pour que le
carburant puisse arriver mais ce qui est
essentiel aujourd'hui est le président
de la République l'a rappelé très
clairement hier soir c'est que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités que les
grévistes ne prennent pas les Français
en otage parce que la situation où il
n'aime pas ça quand on dit que l'on voit
vous vous justifiez vous maintenez que
l'on voit les fils que l'on voit deux
jours comme de nuit devant les stations
essence notamment en Île-de-France et
dans les Hauts-de-France sont totalement
inacceptables et puis la responsabilité
c'est aussi celle évidemment des grands
énergéticiens qui peuvent et doivent se
mettre à la table des discussions pour
procéder à des revalorisations
salariales dans une période où
à cause des grandes variations de prix
de l'énergie ils ont engrangé un certain
nombre de profits c'est total énergie
directement que vous visez ça passe par
une discussion franche avec les
syndicats oui absolument
et elle doit elle doit elle a eu lieu
chez Esso elle doit se elle doit avoir
lieu chez Total maintenant on ne peut
plus attendre est-ce qu'il faut de
nouvelles position alors chez Total
est-ce que vous allez vous lancer dans
des réquisitions mais si la situation
n'est pas débloquée nous serons contre
un d'y parvenir mais ça serait bien
regrettable parce que il n'est pas il
n'est pas du rôle de l'État de devoir
s'immiscer dans des dénégociations qui
devraient avoir lieu en responsabilité
entre le patronat et les syndicats pour
débloquer la situation et éviter une
nouvelle fois de contraindre les
Français à des heures d'attendre devant
les stations essence parce que si ça se
poursuit Emmanuel Macron était optimiste
je le disais hier soir en disant que ça
allait revenir à la normale la semaine
prochaine mais là avec cette reconduite
on ne va pas vers on ne prend pas cette
direction en tout cas il faut que ça
puisse être le cas je crois que nous
traversons des crises d'une ampleur
inégalée sur le plan géostratégique sur
le plan énergétique sur le plan
sanitaire aussi avec une une reprise de
l'épidémie je crois que chacun doit se
comporter en responsabilité soit le les
responsable patronaux les responsables
syndicaux et éviter de laisser les
Français dans la situation à laquelle il
se trouve aujourd'hui dites-moi
Jean-Noël barreau vous appartenez votre
famille politique hier soir a soutenue
un amendement taxant les super
dividendes des entreprises il a été
adopté mettant des faisant apparaître
quelques fractures au sein de au sein de
la majorité puisque ce n'était pas un
texte qui était soutenu par la majorité
pourquoi pourquoi ce texte alors sur la
forme d'abord il arrive relativement
fréquemment que des groupes de la
majorité que ce soit Renaissance horizon
ou le modem face des propositions il
s'avère qu'hier soir l'une de ses
propositions a été adoptée sur le fond
c'est une idée qui est défendue de de
longue date celle de du prélèvement
forfaitaire unique par Jean-Paul Mathey
le président des des députés modem la
question est de savoir comment cette
idée en tout cas de manière très
circonscrite va s'articuler avec la
contribution qui a été décidé au niveau
européen pour mettre à profit les les
les grands énergéticiens qui du fait des
variations des prix de l'énergie ou
engrangé des profits plus importants que
les années précédentes mais
[Musique]
en général est-ce que dans la guerre
Russie Ukraine il y a aussi cette
bataille surgénée le numérique avec des
conséquences chez nous je veux dire
directement les attaques par exemple
contre les hôpitaux des mairies est-ce
qu'elles ont un lien avec cette guerre
elles n'ont pas nécessairement un lien
direct en tout cas il n'y a pas eu dans
les premiers mois de la guerre de de
surcroît des d'attaques mais cela dit
les attaques sont en progression
constante indépendante de la de la
guerre en Ukraine et il se trouve qu'une
partie des des assaillants une partie
des pirates qui mènent ces attaques se
trouve géographiquement dans un certain
nombre de pays comme la Russie qui ont
vis-à-vis de leurs voisins des attitudes
que nous condamnons face à cette menace
le gouvernement agit et agit avec avec
j'ai vu que vous alliez il y a une
agence nationale qui existe là vous
allez mettre davantage de moyens c'est
ça oui les les attaques qui se qui ont
été perpétrées ces dernières semaines à
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes à la
mairie de Caen ou au Département de
Seine-Maritime dimanche dernier nous que
la menace cyber est une grande menace de
notre temps et face à cela nous avons un
certain nombre de réponses l'Agence
nationale pour la sécurité des systèmes
d'information dont l'excellence est
reconnue dans le monde entier va être
renforcée dans ses effectifs avec une
cinquantaine d'effectifs supplémentaires
comme la décider la première ministre
c'est cela va nous permettre à la fois
de
prévenir ces attaques avec des
programmes de prévention notamment pour
les organismes d'importance vitale comme
les collectivités et les administrations
et les hôpitaux et puis lorsque des
attaques surviennent et bien de
d'accompagner les entreprises les
collectivités les particuliers dans la
remédiation c'est-à-dire la réparation
des dégâts qui sont causés parce que on
pourrait être la cible en fait data qui
paralyserait le pays ça c'est un
scénario qui est envisagé sur le
numérique lorsque je me suis rendu à
Corbeil-Essonnes après l'attaque qui a
frappé cet hôpital j'ai été frappé de la
brutalité des conséquences de cette
attaque avec des communisés question
électroniques mises à plat des
communications électroniques aussi
basiques que les emails la téléphonie ou
les une alarme en salle de naissance et
donc ce qu'il nous faut réussir c'est la
prévention c'est à dire d'éviter que ces
attaques puissent être perpétrées bien
souvent ces attaques sont
cibles des d'abord elle cible un peu
tout le monde mais elle elle s'infiltre
dans les organismes ou dans les
organisations au travers de négligence
ou parce que un collaborateur ou un
agent clique sur sur un mail qui est qui
est piégé et donc il nous faut à la fois
protéger en termes de logiciels nos
organisations mais à la fois former nos
collaborateurs et nous avons un autre
outil à côté de l'Agence nationale pour
la sécurité des systèmes d'information
et s'il y a de l'informatique c'est
cyber malveillance.gouv.fr je veux le
dire à vos auditeurs lorsque vous avez
un doute vous pouvez contacter cyber
malveillance.gouv.fr à la fois en amont
pour la prévention à la fois en aval
pour la remédiation
ce site a été saisissant 76000 fois
l'année dernière et apporte des solution
très concrètes que vous soyez
particulier entreprise association ou
collectivités
avec la crise de l'énergie est-ce que
les particuliers vont se voir couper
l'accès à Internet à distance là pendant
l'hiver est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
délestages on l'avait vous l'avez évoqué
non alors le secteur du numérique est
des télécoms fait sa part de l'effort en
trouvant tous les tous les moyens pour
réduire sa consommation énergétique et
parmi les engagements qui ont été pris
par les opérateurs télécoms il y a celui
de baisser la température de baisser la
lumière dans leur locaux de bureau et de
commerce il y a celui de d'optimiser la
consommation de leur réseau pour là
aussi économiser et les efforts par
exemple qui vont être consentis par un
opérateur comme Orange mais c'est vrai
des autres également vont permettre
d'économiser la consommation d'une d'une
ville de la taille de Chartres à peu
près sur l'optimisation de de la
consommation électrique des réseaux et
puis effectivement s'agissant des box
l'engagement qui a été pris c'est de
généraliser le mode veille sur les Box
qui permet de réduire la consommation
énergétique lorsque la box n'est pas
utilisée évidemment le le ça reste une
option à la main de l'utilisateur mais
pour les box existantes et plus et et
naturellement pour les box à venir les
ce à quoi les opérateurs télécoms sont
engagés c'est que et bien un mode veille
puisse être mis par défaut ou en tout
cas automatiquement et que le que le que
l'utilisateur puisse décider d'activer
ou désactiver pour réduire sa
consommation de coupure à distance quoi
vous allez pas à distance mettre en
veille quoi auto couper on va pas couper
la box à distance ni nous ni le
gouvernement ni les opérateurs en
revanche si nous ne réussissons pas ce
grand effort collectif de réduction de
10% de la consommation énergétique à
l'horizon des des deux ans comme la
souhaitait le président de la République
et bien nous prenons le risque que en
cas d'annulaire très froid nous en
arrivions à des solutions de dernier
recours et le solution dernier recours
c'est le délestage c'est à dire
[Musique]
et bien de cette de cet effort que nous
faisons dans le court terme pour réduire
la consommation énergétique du secteur
Jean-Noël Barrault sans rentrer dans les
détails mais quand même c'est une
question souveraineté ou en est-on la
des transferts de données aux Américains
est-ce que les Français peuvent avoir
des garanties les Français les Européens
oui alors la France et l'Europe sont
très engagés dans la protection des
données des Européens aujourd'hui c'est
donner elles sont stockées et elles
transit au travers de de solutions qui
sont bien souvent américaines et et aux
États-Unis le président dispose du droit
de de réquisitionner ces données en cas
de menace sur la sécurité intérieure et
c'est évidemment
inacceptable pour les Européens de voir
leur donner réquisitionner c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons décidé
avec le président de la République la
première ministre Bruno Le Maire de
faire en sorte que les administrations
lorsqu'elles collectent et stockent des
données des Français le fasse dans des
solutions qui sont immunes à cette
faculté des États-Unis de réquisitionner
et donner européenne alors il y a
effectivement une décision prise aux
Etats-Unis hier pour essayer de se de se
conformer aux règles de protection des
données en Europe à la rgpd en
particulier la Commission européenne les
cnils européennes vont analyser cette
décision américaine pour voir si
effectivement elle conduisent à une
meilleure protection des données
personnelles des Français qui peuvent
s'inquiéter oui bien sûr une question
d'actualité dernière question Jean-Noël
Barrault selon une enquête de Mediapart
le PSG aurait payé une agence numérique
pour nuire à certains joueurs enfin ou
contre-attaquer est-ce que vous avez été
saisi ou est-ce que vous allez vous
saisir de cette histoire en fait on est
saisi plus généralement de tous ces
problèmes de désinformation et de
manipulation dans l'espace numérique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec la
ministre de la Culture la ministre des
Affaires étrangères nous allons lancer
les états généraux de l'information
souhaitée par le Président de la
République pour adresser un certain
nombre de ses problèmes et faire en
sorte que l'information soit de soit de
qualité et que quand on s'était confirmé
cette histoire est-ce que c'est légal ou
pas le PSG démon mais bon avoir utilisé
avoir eu recours à une agence en tout
cas ça n'est pas des comportements qui
sont souhaitables dans l'espace
numérique et donc l'objectif de ces
états généraux de l'information qui vont
commencer d'ici la fin de l'année et
bien c'est de lister l'ensemble des
sujets non traités encore dans l'espace
numérique pour pouvoir apporter une
sécurité une qualité de l'information
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que les
journalistes ceux qui produisent
l'information véritable puisse être
rémunéré correctement et pour faire en
sorte que le dans l'espace numérique et
bien on n'est pas comme ça une
propagation de la haine de la violence
de la des informations que les
journalistes etc c'est les trolls ce
qu'on appelle les trolls il peut y avoir
une chasse au troll c'est pas légal il
est trop lou c'est légal
il y a un certain nombre de règles à
redéfinir dans l'espace numérique pour
assurer ou pour garantir une d'une part
la qualité de l'information et d'autre
part le un partage ou en tout un partage
dans le de l'information et un espace
public numérique puisque aujourd'hui
vous le savez on est dans un espace
numérique et complètement fractionné on
est enfermé bien souvent dans des dans
des bulles de filtres où on ne voit que
l'information qui correspond à certaines
de nos préférences et de nos croyances
et on finit par ne plus avoir la manière
ou à ne plus être confronté à des
oppositions contrairement aux autres le
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre délégué en
charge de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications étaient invités de
Sud Radio merci beaucoup